the most insane twist just took place in
mha and I for one did not see this
unbelievable sacrifice coming the last
chapter was met with a ton of
controversy but this chapter was way
crazier than anything we saw last time
what just happened is about to have a
massive impact on the entire War
including the fight between Deku and
shigaraki so we need to talk about it
right now you guys know how this works
if you enjoy my major content leave a
quick like and comment right now for
that YouTube algorithm and we are trying
to awaken the full potential of our
Quirk here on the channel by hitting 2
million subscribers help us out by
subscribing right now and let's do it
finally this video will contain mha
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter the battle portion of
the toga vs ochako confrontation came to
an end as ochako managed to convince
toga that she genuinely cares about her
and that she appreciates toga for who
she is toga always felt like her true
nature was rejected by Society right
down to her natural and genuine smile
being referred to as the smile of a
deviant by her own parents told toga
that she has a beautiful smile that she
is the cutest girl in the world and that
if she needs blood ochako would be happy
to give her some for the rest of her
life these words finally got through to
toga she accepted ochako's compassion
and friendship as genuine and instead of
attacking mochiko toga hugged her soon
after toga's supply of twice his blood
ran out and all the Clones that she had
been using for Sad Man's parade vanished
the fight was over however as I
mentioned in my last few videos ocheko
suffered a severe Stab Wound from toga
back in chapter 392 and I've been saying
repeatedly how weird it is that in the
last few chapters ochako's severe injury
was barely mentioned she just continued
to engage in physical combat as usual
while also using her Quirk at the same
time and I was beginning to think that
horikoshi wasn't going to give the star
wound The Narrative attention it clearly
deserves thankfully the latest chapter
focuses greatly on ochako's injury and
it produces perhaps the most intriguing
moment of self-sacrifice in the entire
story I personally didn't see this
particular series of events coming if
you predicted this let me know down in
the comments but let's break it all down
right now we start off with the
aftermath of Sad Man's parade with all
the Clones dissolving and the heroes who
were almost consumed by the Clones just
barely surviving the onslaught a half
dead Endeavor seems to have been
shielding his family from the Clones
with his own body and thankfully he did
manage to protect them all long enough
for the Clones to dissipate although I
have to say he himself looks like
absolute hell this guy has been through
some stuff man that's for sure Ida was
also almost taken out by the Clones but
they begin to dissolve just as they are
about to swarm him Hawks was probably in
the worst trouble of all one of the
Clones a clone that looks like a cross
between toga and twice was actually
slashing him with a 9 life and she was
about to kill him at any moment Hawks
looks like he was either unable or
unwilling to defend himself and in fact
he says to the toga clone that twice
really was a good guy but as with the
other clones this clone disappears
before it can kill its Target and we see
that as this clone disappears it appears
to be crying back at the place where
toga and ochiko had clashed we see that
ochako is now lying on the ground her
injury finally taking its toll on her
toga is standing above her and holding
her knife along with that gear she uses
to quickly suck people's blood and store
it toga says that the knife she is
holding allowed her to become the people
she loved but she filled it with anger
and hatred in order to create a world
that she thought would be easier to live
in toga seems to be experiencing regret
judging by the expression on her face
but we don't get to focus on that for
long because toga begins to experience
terrible pain this pain is the price
that toga pays for transforming into
other people and using their quirks and
it's def definitely not a pleasant side
effect but toga's attention right now
isn't on her own suffering it is an
ochako who is clearly dying from the
stab wound that toga gave her toga notes
that ochako had used zero gravity to
ensure that all the heroes had a safe
landing she didn't stop using her Quirk
until she knew that everyone was okay
even though she was in an incredible
amount of pain as a result of her injury
even though she lost so much blood she
refused to let anyone drop No Matter
What In This Moment ochako appears to be
dying she can't move and she feels like
her brain has become disconnected from
her body ochako's time is running out
she managed to talk toga down and save
everyone else from dying but now she is
about to die toga realizes this and she
remembers how ochako offered to give her
blood for the rest of her life if that
meant that toga would stop hurting
others she also remembers how ochako
told her that she has a beautiful smile
and that she is the cutest girl in the
world tolgari realizes just how
genuinely pure and kind ochako is and it
is in that moment that toga makes a
decision she tells ochako that she lost
too much blood because she kept moving
even after toga stabbed her toga also
tells ochako that the league of villains
wants to destroy everything and create a
new world the kind of world that would
be much better for someone like toga to
live it that is why toga loved the
league so much but now she knows that
there are things in this world that are
even more precious than that new world
ochako's words made toga really happy
and she can't stand the thought of
letting ochako die like this even if
that brought about a better world for
people like toga and so toga drinks some
of ochuka's blood the blood that had
already escaped her body and she uses
that blood to become ochako in the past
when toga had been on the brink of death
twice had created a toga clone and then
used the clone's blood to save toga by
giving her a blood transfusion the Clone
is biologically identical to the
original so the blood is perfectly
compatible however toga doesn't have any
more of twice's blood so she can't just
create a clone she has to turn into
ochako herself and then give her own
blood to ochako in order to save her
life when toga becomes someone she loves
using her Quirk then her blood also
becomes their blood meaning the blood is
perfectly compatible with the person
whom she transformed into toga declares
that she will save ochako by giving her
all of her own blood and she then uses
that blood draining device of hers to
transfuse her own blood into ojako
ochako tries to tell toga not to do it
but ochako doesn't really have the power
to resist toga closes up the Stab Wound
and then she begins transferring her own
blood into ochako she wonders if watch
had successfully captured toga whether
she would have really given her blood
for the rest of her life ochiko could
have just captured her or even killed
her for being a villain and a deviant
but toga believes that ochako was
genuinely concerned learned about her
well-being even though she is a villain
even though toga hurt and stabbed
ochika's friends and even though she
stabbed ochiko herself ochek was still
genuinely cared about toga and her
well-being as she lies down beside
ochako while the blood transfusion
proceeds toga says you're weird ochako
With Tears In Her Eyes woja corresponds
by saying right back at you and she asks
toga why she is doing this why would she
give up her own life for a hero toga
proclaims that she will live her life
the way that she wants to she won't let
anyone capture her even if Ocho would
have kept her word that's just not the
way that she wants to live her life she
apologizes to ochako for stabbing her
and for yelling at her she says that
even though she tried to put her past
behind her it was still haunting her her
traumatic childhood was still there
inside her heart but ochako reaching out
to toga and being kind to her made toga
finally realize what was really missing
from her life ochako finally made toga
realize what it really means happy for
her entire life toga wanted to become
all these different people and she drank
the blood from people she envied and
loved the most she thought that true
love meant consuming someone's blood so
that you can become one with them but
now toga understands that this was not
true love true love is not consuming
someone's blood to become one with them
instead true love means loving someone
so much that you want to give them your
blood not take theirs away toga says
that if she had met someone she loved
sooner this world would have been a much
easier place to live it but even so she
is himiko toga and she lived her life
exactly how she wanted to toga hugs
ochako and her final thoughts are that
she has the cutest smile and that she is
a normal girl and as toga presumably
dies so that ochako can live this
chapter comes to an end toga finally
understood that truly caring for someone
means giving them everything not taking
everything from that and even though she
made many terrible mistakes and did many
terrible things with this ultimate
sacrifice toga will save ochako's life
and a tone for her sins wow this was
powerful despite the fact that this
chapter wasn't about fighting an action
it was one of the most intense and
emotional chapters in the entire series
with this toga's character Arc is
concluded in the best way possible she
managed to atone at least for some of
the stuff that she's done in the past
and ochako gets to live after nearly
giving her life in order to save
everyone now this is a Shonen and fake
out deaths have happened in mha before I
recall Gran Torino and like bakugou two
times but I will say that if horikoshi
decides to make toga's death a fake out
here it will drastically hurt the story
I'm not saying that I want toga to die
per se but this chapter just gave us a
very powerful narrative and a truly
emotional final sacrifice from toga that
partially redeems her and also makes her
a multi-dimensional and multi-faceted
character in the end if horikoshi takes
this back and makes it so that both Ocho
and toga survive somehow it would
definitely cheapen this powerful moment
I hate to say it toga fans but her
sacrifice here might be the best thing
for her character and for the story what
do you guys think did toga really just
sacrifice her life for ochako or will
they both manage to survive somehow when
Shonen logic kicks in what did you think
of this chapter overall personally I
thought it was great because it really
completed toga's character development
in a meaningful way I've always said
that yes Society treated her unfairly
because of her unique biological makeup
and there is no excuse for how her own
parents condemned her and labeled her a
deviant because of her Quirk but at the
same time what she was doing wasn't
right either you can't just decide to
start consuming other people's blood
because your biology makes you desire it
you might think it's a compliment
because it means you love that person
but the person being attacked and
drained of their blood certainly
wouldn't see things that way so it was
never that simple with toga yes she was
mistreated but she also had a warped
view of love and she was doing things
that couldn't be excused no matter how
you look at it and that is why I loved
this chapter because toga finally
realized that love wasn't about
consuming the blood of others to become
them love is caring about someone so
much that you would give up all of your
own blood for them honestly that was
excellent did you guys like how toga's
character was developed in the end let
me know down below finally how will
these crazy events affect deku's fight
with shigaraki how will Deku react when
he learns that ochako almost died but
she was saved in the end because the
villain himikotoga sacrificed her own
life to save ochako will this maybe make
Deku even more determined to try to save
shigaraki because if toga could atone
for her villainous acts maybe shigaraki
could too could that actually end up
becoming deku's greatest weakness going
forward like could deku's determination
to save shigaraki lead him to pull
punches and allow shigaraki to come out
on top I definitely want to hear what
you guys think in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more amateur content in the future leave
a quick like to let me know and if you
want to help us get to that insane 2
million subscribers Mark subscribe right
now it would help me out a lot as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys